Adam made me a hero to my kid and I will
never help you every day
I hope you guys are ready for some
serious sugar because Ben Affleck just
told the sweetest story you'll hear all
day
it meant that's right the actor stopped
by Jimmy Kimmel Live on Tuesday and
opened up about his son Samuels eighth
birthday which they celebrated last week
Ben explained that he's shooting his
upcoming flick the last duel in London
movies been really fun really excited
Adam driver Jody comer and Matt Damon
really Scott directing it's going to be
it's really fun but he made sure to fly
back to LA to be with his little boy on
his special day you know I'm a Dwarfs
dad I get certainly you know half the
time with my son and I really it was his
birthday birthday oh so I said to them
like I'll do whatever the schedule needs
but like 27 I got to be in LA so you
know they set it up where I've kind of
shooting right up till the 27th and I
had to scramble and drive and ruin we
could play in the boom and land and and
I was only right in time for his for his
birthday Ben said he had a bunch of
presents shipped over and was going to
pick them up and go to the surprise
party and that's when he backed things
up just a little bit and shared a small
but crucial detail about his son my son
knows that I do movies that are kind of
fake and his mom does movies and that's
all pretend but he also knows that Star
Wars is real like that job needs to get
done and I can do my fake you know do an
important job yeah Sam big star Wars fan
and since then is currently working with
Adam driver aka kylo Ren then earned
some major cool dad points I told him
like I'm actually in this movie with
kylo Ren oh right and his mind like
opened into like
okay now back to the birthday bash Ben
said he knew something was wrong when he
got off his 11 hour flight and saw the
look on his assistant space I said where
the presents and he was like they didn't
get here oh so I had to show up to you
know my son's party with Lopez with no
gift yeah that's bad and it was like the
surf sinking awful feeling sad right
well dry those eyes because Adam saved
the freaking day he said well Adam heard
you say it was your son's birthday and
so he called it's resistant got your
address and sent some presents and
signed a card and a picture of from kylo
Ren
and I took those presents yeah it gets
even better
I watched him open all his other
presents and I said in my presence
didn't get here on time company is it
but I did get a present from somebody
who really wanted to make sure you had a
gift he was like who I said kylo Ren I
mean the build-up is so good
you opened the presents I played him the
video of kylo Ren and and it was like
you know what's better than that readily
moving and powerful moment but yeah Adam
made me a hero to my kid and I will
never you have window this is the sort
of news the world needs more of right
people doing sweet stuff for other
people as for Ben he said Adams kindness
left a major mark on him it's a really
good lesson like doing those small
gestures of kindness because you have no
idea I mean for every I guess it does
the toys the kylo Ren doll without Ren
they go in the coloring thing and a
little picture of Tyler and sign back
over and it would it meant
I told you guys sweetest story you'll
hear all day
et recently sat down with Ben to talk
about his new movie the way back where
he plays a recovering alcoholic who gets
a chance to turn his life around when
he's given the chance to coach a high
school basketball team
the idea that life gets better that you
can get better that you can overcome
your obstacles is a really important one
to me and that's the approach that I
liked about this movie Ben has been open
about his own struggles with alcohol and
his current sobriety what was
interesting for me was to be able to
define the story myself the way I see it
which is really one of hope I am loving
this side of Ben Affleck of course et
will be here to bring you all the latest
on Ben's so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Holly
Stevens and I'll see you soon
[Music]